кицька область сир з аутсайдерів реформа
децентралізація поки тут створа на тертці
1 карту реально помада децентралізації
біля кінські гру моді побажати atarax
об'їзду немає 4 сцени з чеки прибрала собі
одну радує в одного голову тепер без 6
нормальних по тій тут може ви вирішите
самі без відповіді ж не району цю
обласну володію куди проводите нас не
ви просто ось і альтернативний джерело
енергії які фірми зворотної щоб тут
роблю все наріжте граматики транспорт
та й як придбати комунальну техніку
щоб його z з митя то препарати волоки
центру turn та призначений для прибирання
з неї ву та прибирання wool та згини та
запланованим змінена міда constitute
ділянці не децентралізації романи
відривати чоловіки звістка винен це навіть
бюджету у середньому u2 чим менше подарунки
у розпалі та вниз раніше
точку до латинських громади сокира і ви
вирішили відра манту ватої будди на
культури вузький tigers ділячи видих
культурно жити, а тут зовсім заповнилася
залежний рокки в тому ж назаро мило
сцена зовсім приводу дверцята такі
великі
41 мільйон гривень бюджетка латинського ну
модена царик так і грушею
всі 4 сила спокон віків і бачіли без
ділянки на кішці
виділяє іржава з субвенції засіки нам
це ціну
його свиту пишу червові кошти які будуть
виділені нам державою виглядати
субвенцій для розвитку
інфраструктури
ванни дадуть по штоф а ми будемо за промінь від
через свою кішку вже інвесторів для
розвитку нашої та громади з диваном
іноді централізація csc речах поки
задоволений і 1 знач не я тут уже 30 ролке
врублю та й різна стосувалася нарада
начиталася а куди покинутою ще до них
раби
так ми вже будемо самі допомоги вже сесії
тут же кустарним думати будемо 6-ро бути
від дорогу на дорогу
реалізацію цих planika латинського
громада закладіть на вище вигляд
ефективності нової влади червоний вигляд
роботи петрою м103 наповнити місяців та
бюджет у тип рук
стіна бо наші з них свиноферма ж
кілька місяців зачин вона на карантин